dans la crise exclure est une faute
qu'est-ce qui se passe nous avons perdu
des électeurs
où sont ils allés ses électeurs soit
dans l'abstention parce qu'on n'a pas
été assez attractif
soit ils sont allés dès le premier tour
voter manuel macron et donc il y a
beaucoup d'électeurs de droite et du
centre qui t'ont vote emmanuel macron
donc si on veut un jour rassembler notre
famille il faut parler à l'ensemble de
nos électeurs donc rejeté les a rejetées
les autres ça conduit à toi à quoi ça
conduit à rétrécir à chaque élection
notre espace politique et comme cela ça
va conduire à une stratégie d'une droite
dure d'une droite qui ne sera pas une
droite de rassemblement qui sera une
droite refermée sur elle-même et ça ce
n'est pas bon je reste fidèle au pacte
fondateur de l'ump
c'est à dire le pacte qui anime les
républicains c'est à dire l'alliance de
la droite et du sang je suis pour le
respect des diversités et je ne suis pas
favorable aux exclusions que les uns ou
les autres puissent se mettre en congé
parce qu'à un moment ou un autre leur
situation serait pas compatible
c'est possible mais exclure c'est mettre
en cause l'idée de diversité qui doit
présider à une perspective de
rassemblement
est ce que les français n'attendent pas
de la cohérence justement vous nous
parlez de l'ump qui remonte quand même
maintenant une quinzaine d'années et on
voit qu'aujourd'hui il y aurait quand
même peut-être une plus grande cohérence
à avoir un nouveau parti comme on
l'avait fait une époque où le nouveau
centre s'était créé sur les ruines du
modem est ce que les constructif cette
branche centriste de l air ne devrait
pas aujourd'hui créer un nouveau
mouvement
je pense que la droite gagne quant à
elle est associée au centre j'ai entendu
dans la période récente que les
élections se gagnent est à droite
moi j'avais toujours appris avec valéry
giscard d'estaing qui je suis né en
politique où les élections se gagnent
est au centre emmanuel macron pendant
que la gauche d élection se gagne à
gauche pendant que la droite se disaient
les élections se gagnent à droite
emmanuel macron a dit des élections se
gagnent au centre et c'est lui qui a
gagné
je pense qu'un nouveau cette règle d'or
s'est imposé
pour gagner au centre il faut une
alliance de la droite d'une raie droite
mais d'un centre d'un vrai sens